and exciting today's people from all
walks of life celebrate becoming the
seventh state to legalize gay marriage
we're here talking to excited couples
about how they feel on this historic day
oh hi hi hi yeah it's a very historic
day for civil rights and for gay
Americans and Americans all over the
country we said that to be a
conversation you know to me because we
didn't know this was gonna pass so darn
fast
so were you guys a couple are we a
couple come on girl let's get serious so
my name is LaShawn and this right here
is my family it's just Samuel yeah well
we've three years it's been forever we
believe forever it's really important to
know the person who is the bride I am
the bride bill to the bill to little
Toto about your plans well you know we
never thought it was important to have a
piece of paper so there's not any plans
where do you think you guys will get
married we know there's a lot of hidden
costs in a way everywhere we go get
married over here and over there and in
the sky and on a cloud it sounds like
it's gonna be a big wedding well you
know the moon and rose
we really need to talk about whether or
not we think it's fair to even get
married when it's still illegal in so
many other states look at him look at
him that's my man with his big hearts
that I'm sorry my husband you my husband
now well we just okay we just don't want
to rush into anything because stuff gets
overturned remember what happened in
California I won't get a 14-karat ring
the size of 14 love carrots that's
what's up doc well you two certainly
seem excited yeah do we seem excited
okay congratulations I hope you guys
have a wonderful life together just we
really just didn't think it was gonna
pass it's gonna be we gonna have a house
that's shaped like a unicorn and we
gonna have five little girls the names
gonna be at me carousel sequin
abercrombie and phantom and we gonna
have a little dog named Ruffalo and the
dog gonna have a cat named myriad
you